[Musique]
avec julien chez les dames bonjour
julien bonjour conduit à des tensions
sont apparues du côté de la moldavie ces
tensions font craindre peut-être
l'imminence d'un conflit dans ce petit
pays voisins de l'ukraine effectivement
on va commencer pas vous montrer une
carte de courrier international vous en
parlais tout à l'heure de la
transnistrie c'est une région
séparatiste moldave qui se trouve juste
à l'est de la moldavie la région avec
une population majoritairement pro russe
et seulement reconnue par la russie elle
pourrait bientôt peut-être devenir un
nouveau théâtre de la guerre en ukraine
des explosions ont été entendues dans la
région ces derniers jours et cela
inquiète au plus au plus haut en plus
haut lieu les autorités moldaves dans ce
cas pourquoi la moldavie serait-elle une
cible des russes et bien parce que comme
l'ukraine la moldavie est un ancien pays
satellite de l'urss depuis sa chute en
1991 la moldavie pays le plus pauvre du
continent européen cherche un équilibre
entre l'occident et la russie mais
depuis quelques années écrit fort une
pole ici récemment depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de maya sans doute qu'on voit
ici à la présidence le pays se tourne
résolument vers l'union européenne
son dossier de candidature a lieu est en
cours d'étude mais l'objectif rêvé de la
russie et bien serait d'étendre
l'influencé russe de du dombass jusqu au
dessin avoir jusqu'à la moldavie
c'est-à-dire d'étendre son influence sur
la mer noire la presse européenne
revient aussi longuement sur l'arrêt
depuis donc ce matin de la livraison de
gaz russe vers la pologne et vers la
bulgarie effectivement incroyable
ironise le standard news bulgare parce
que cela ressemble à une mauvaise blague
de la russie explique le quotidien car
après vérification tous les accords
passés avec moscou pour obtenir du gaz
ont été respectées notamment sur la
question des paiements rappelle sociale
c'est-à-dire paiements en dollars et non
pas en roubles comme l'exigent
aujourd'hui la russie ce serait donc à
la bulgarie de réfléchir à d'éventuelles
sanctions économiques au cas où moscou
camperait sur ses positions du côté
polonais pas question de céder au
chantage moscou cherche à contourner les
sanctions européennes
et bien tant pis écrit l'article du
journal polonais et les prix pour les
particuliers de n'augmenteront pas sur
les autorités et il y aura suffisamment
de gaz pour les prochains mois les cuves
sont actuellement remplis à 80 % et pour
combler le mans et bien la pologne
apportera du gaz liquéfié du qatar est
des états unis notamment et d'autres
pays pourraient suivre l'exemple
polonais les pays baltes avait déjà dit
stop au gaz russe début avril à quand le
tour de l'italie s'interroge la
repubblica car après l'allemagne
l'italie et l'autre grand pays européen
qui dépend fortement du gaz russe rome
importe 40 5% des importations de ce nom
de son gaz de russie et il ya quelques
jours le président du conseil italien
mario draghi a signé des accords avec
plusieurs pays d'afrique pour importer
du gaz je cite la guerre en ukraine se
joue aussi sur le front économique et
énergétique écrit le journal
en représailles rome pourrait aussi
nationaliser une raffinerie située en
sicile usine contrôlé par un consortium
russe et qui a la capacité de traiter du
gaz liquéfié et on va parler de la
politique en france à 13 ans emmanuel
macron consulte toute la semaine en vue
de la formation de son futur
gouvernement et de l'annoncer galons de
son premier ministre et déjà il subit
des pressions de la part des partenaires
sociaux oui des partenaires sociaux qui
n'ont pas digéré la manière dont
l'elysée l'elysée les avaient traités
lors du premier quinquennat de lors du
premier quinquennat pardon et surtout
lors de la réforme des retraites avorté
en 2020 à cause de la pandémie et dans
une tribune au monde laurent berger le
secrétaire général de la cfdt réclame
l'instauration d'un vrai dialogue cette
fois ci entre le futur gouvernement et
les partenaires sociaux il faut de la
considération de l'écouté et du respect
crie-t-il auquel cas le pays n'y
résisterait pas alors à quoi pourrait
ressembler ces échanges entre entre
l'exécutif et les syndicats
l'opinion imagine un emmanuel macron
presque timide toquer à la porte à des
partenaires sociaux pour discuter de
quoi eh bien vous le voyez ici de la
réforme des retraites projet qui avait
fait débat lors de la campagne notamment
sur la question de l'âge de départ l'âge
légal de départ m'a comme emmanuel
macron avait dit 60 58 64 ans et si et
si emmanuel macron était plus flexible
sur la question et s'il changer de
méthode c'est la question que se pose
l'opinion on l'a déjà vu entre les deux
tours il avait fait preuve il avait fait
preuve de souplesse de là à rêver écrit
le quotidien on y est presque ce qui est
sûr et bien c'est qu'ils emmanuel macron
devra rendre sa réforme aimable ou au
moins tolérable je cite autrement dit
une réforme acceptée par les syndicats
est validé par le parlement et pour
obtenir une majorité aux prochaines
législatives qui auront lieu au mois de
juin emmanuel macron avait envisagé la
création d'un grand parti unique du
centre et ça ne plaît pas à tout le
monde en fait ça me plait quasiment à
personne sauf aux parties de la
république marche le parti majoritaire
pas question pour les alliés du modem et
d'horizons d'edouard philippe de se
diluer encore je cite dans un grand
parti écrit le parisien entre emmanuel
macron edouard philippe le torchon ne
brûle pas encore mais on ne peut pas
dire que les relations entre le
président et son ancien premier ministre
sont au beau fixe je ne me sens pas tenu
par un deal quand on ne m'invite pas
autour de la table dixit edouard
philippe
on savait que les femmes avaient une
espérance plus grande de vie une
espérance de vie sains plus grande que
les hommes on a appris que la doyenne de
l'humanité était une française elle
s'appelle lucie rendons la voix si elle
vit dans le sud de la france elle est
devenue officiellement hier la doyenne
de l'humanité après le décès de canettes
à cana de 13 mois son aîné à l'étagé
deux cent dix huit ans elle est née en
1904 arles dans la france de la belle
époque sous la troisième république
saramontins type a condamné ces péchés
mignons écrite dit elle au figaro un
cocktail porto chocolat et ne lui parlez
surtout pas de la mort elle de profiter
de la vie jusqu'au bout de toute façon
dit elle je crois que le bon dieu m'a
oublié elle a bien raison de profiter
merci beaucoup pour cette revue de
presse